we're told that linday isn't sure how to
subtract 3 853
we are told lindy isn't sure how to
subtract 853
minus 283
help lindy by choosing an expression
that is the same as 853 minus 283
so pause this video and see if you can
answer it on your own before we work
through it together
all right now when we look at all the
choices they all start with 853.
now this first choice they subtract out
200 that makes sense because we have
200s right over there
then they subtract out 50
and then they subtract out 3.
so the 200 and the three make sense you
can view 853 minus 283 as
minus two hundreds
minus 80
8 tens right here minus 3 but that's not
what they wrote over here instead of
putting an 80 here they put a 50 so we
can rule that out
here we have 253 minus 20 minus 800
minus 3.
well this is a little bit strange
because we don't have two tens we have
two hundreds and we don't have eight
hundreds we have eight tens so this is
also incorrect
now it's probably going to be this one
but let's just make sure we feel
comfortable with this
so this one has 853 minus 200
minus 50
minus 30. does that make sense
well let's think about it what they're
doing is that they're subtracting out
first the 200 so that's this part right
over here so that makes sense they're
subtracting out first that
and then they're subtracting out 53 and
then subtracting out 30.
well that is the same thing as
subtracting out 83 because subtracting
83 is the same thing as subtracting out
53 and then subtracting 30. 53 plus 30
is 83. now you might be wondering why
would they even do it this way well it's
easier to do in your head 853
minus 200 is 653.
you take away 53 from that
so you take away 53 from that and you're
going to be left with 600
and then 600 minus 30
you might recognize that you could use
this as 60 tens minus three tens that's
going to be 57 tens or you might be able
to do it in your head 600 minus 30 is
570. so that's why they broke out they
broke up the 83 instead of just breaking
it up into 80 and 3 they broke it up
into 53 and 30 to match this 53 over
here and so it was easier to work out
the result let's do another example
so here we're asked to fill in the blank
they say 143 minus 79 is the same as
blank minus 80. so pause this video and
see if you can figure this out
so the key here is to realize is that
when you have a difference here as long
as you add or subtract the same amount
to both of these the difference will be
the same
so it looks like they tried to turn the
79 into
it looks like they turned the 79 into an
by adding one and so if we want the
difference to be the same we would add
one to the 143 as well so 143 plus 1 is
144. if we add 1 to both of these
numbers the difference would be the same
and we're done
so it's 144 minus 80.